Okay so yesterday several big reports on
the DCU release that talked about Ezra
Miller's Flash The Rock and also some
things about what's happening with
Wonder Woman in the upcoming James Gunn
full reboot soft reboot that isn't a
proper reboot but it's still a reboot
people on the internet love nothing more
than someone reading a news article out
to them and that's exactly what we're
going to be doing in this very video
we're going to be breaking down what was
said going over what guns debunked and
also our thoughts on the entire
situation if you enjoy it please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for update videos on the news
as we get it gun and saffron will be
unveiling some of their upcoming 10-year
plan very shortly and we'll be going
through all of that so make sure you
don't miss out now firstly I want to
talk about the Ezra Miller thing and
also give my thoughts on what I think is
happening with the flash IGN and variety
both did some things covering it and
according to them sources of told
variety that Warner Brothers Discovery
executives are still willing to work
with Miller according to the report the
fact that Miller is stated up trouble
since they began mental health treatment
last summer has reopened the door to
Miller appearing as the flash again in
the future The Flash movie which is
slated for release November 4th 2023 and
will reportedly feature a lot of DC
characters as it borrows from the
flashpoint story arc from the comic and
restarts everything is slowly growing
its cast whilst also losing a few faces
now we do know that Henry Cavill was due
to cameo in this but this was cutting
the latest screening after he was kicked
to the curb guy didn't deserve it in my
opinion and honestly I think that's the
thing that's caused the biggest uproar
in the DC fandom especially because guns
seems to be keeping other stuff I really
think the first move in the DCU should
have been announcing new movies so that
people could get excited but instead we
had a wave of firings which just put a
black cloud over the entire thing before
we even knew what was happening there's
also the fact that Miller's been a very
very controversial figure and to see
them potentially getting to keep their
role whilst we lose Cavill is no doubt
gonna annoy some people because yeah I I
I'm fully on board the keep caval team
now the article in goes I didn't talk
about the crimes that Miller's been
accused of and the fact that they were
charged with felony burglary out in
Vermont Miller has denied these charges
and the hearing for it will be happening
on the 13th of January IGN then go over
all this stuff that Warner Brothers have
been doing behind the scenes and they
say the past them is legal issues led to
multiple reports including Warner Bros
was planning to part ways with Miller
for future DC films the company was also
apparently planning multiple scenarios
regarding the upcoming Flash movie
including scrapping it entirely then in
August Miller apologized for their
recent Behavior saying they were
struggling from complex mental health
issues the apology to her continued as
Miller reportedly met with WB Discovery
Executives to save The Flash movie in
that meeting Miller reportedly
reaffirmed their commitment to the movie
calling the flash one of their favorite
characters to play Miller reportedly
returned his set for The Flash reshoots
in October which was a sign that WB was
going ahead with a film we also know
there's already a script written for
Flash 2 which was reportedly put
together just in case the flash does
well of course the entire future plan
for DC is still up in the air thanks to
the recent creative takeover by James
Gunn and Peter Safran Wonder Woman 3 has
already apparently been scrapped along
with cavaline Johnson's departures
Cavill and gal gadar reportedly shot
cameos for The Flash movie that have
been cut as pot of gun and serpin's
plans now with all this you have to bear
in mind that the decision over whether
to keep Miller or not boils down to gun
and saffron Man of Steel 2 had a script
in the works and that was scrapped so
the flash to having one doesn't mean
it's greenlit now personally I think
whatever's happening with Ezra Miller on
the flash is gonna remain a closely
guarded secret until after the movie is
out I really like Warner Brothers is
going to announce anything until after
the movie's released and they can see
what the general feeling around it is
makes absolutely no sense to talk about
recasts until dinner how it's performed
and saying Ezra is out could ruin the
promotion of the film Warner Brothers
already booked a Super Bowl slot for the
trailer and they are clearly banking on
this movie being big it'll see both
Michael Keaton and Ben Affleck playing
Batman and they clearly saw that no way
her money which is why they're risking a
lot on it there was a comment made
recently that said the flash was
supposed to be the best DC movie since
the Dark Knight and it joins the
pantheon of films that have also been
called that every [ __ ] DC film is
that Shazam 2 is gonna be the best DC
film since the last DC film that was the
best DC film since the Dark Knight I
could actually reply to someone asking
about this and he said I don't know
what's out there about Ezra but our
slate is eight to ten years but we will
only be announcing some of it this month
I call BS on this because the guy really
checks out rumors on his films and he's
debunked so much that I think there's no
way he wouldn't have seen the stuff
about Ezra Miller that's pretty much
been a constant news cycle for the past
year or whatever I think he's done this
because again Warner Brothers haven't
made a decision so they don't want to
put anything thing out about it yet now
I've always said that if DC reboot then
they need to do a full reboot because
the backlash over actors they've cut
will end up being too much you can't
keep some especially those as
controversial as Ezra Miller and get rid
of fan favorites without it causing
issues over the last couple of years
we've seen multiple multiple actors
fight from things because of allegations
and if Ezra gets charged it's double
standards to keep them even good himself
was fired from Marvel over tweets and to
see someone keeping their job after
being charged with a crime would be a PR
disaster in my opinion now Zachary Levi
also released a statement about the
rumors and he said I have no idea what's
ultimately going to happen to me I think
I'm in a pretty good position I think we
made a great movie I think it's going to
do well reasonably well I hope so but
again regardless of that if they decide
at some point that hey this is the way
we gotta go
I mean them you know them is the breaks
that's how it goes and I hope that I
hope that people enjoyed at whatever
point I finished playing the role of
Shazam I hope people enjoyed my tenure
playing the role and that they come with
me to whatever else I get to go and do
that's it okay so
I don't want to it's it's hard for me to
see all these random comments and and
like basically lies and things that
people were throwing around online and
not want to respond because I hate lies
I hate deceit I hate Injustice so much
um and so I want to set records straight
by the way so does James he's been doing
this for a long time that's why he's so
active on Twitter because he really
wants people to know what's up truly and
wanting to set record straight and so
it's you know that that's why you'll see
act action from me or him or other
people coming to defense it's not
because we want to get tied up in some
random argument with an Internet troll
it's because we're trying to help cut
through all of the this random you know
deceitful banter that just keeps going
around and around because a lot of
people who are very good kind people who
really like Shazam or these other things
are getting worried like oh is this all
falling apart is this all going away
everyone just take a breath I know we've
seen some characters some actors that
are taking an exit and I know that's
difficult that's difficult for even
you know what I mean I was hoping I got
to work with a lot of these folks but
it's just not the way it's gonna go down
right now and I I think you all need to
whoever out there is still like all
drummed up and pissed off like just
trust that James
is so look if you haven't watched what
he did with guardians which was a total
Niche property that he actually brought
really awesome life to and his reboot of
Suicide Squad that was better than the
first one he really made something
incredible there he understands comic
books guys he understands World building
he understands how to do right by the
Canon and also by the by the characters
and also by the audience and Peter's
there to be an increase an incredible
Diplomat and business person I've worked
with him now for years
just breathe it's uh it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be better than okay so lots
of things to take from that but I think
the main thing is that Zack doesn't know
like at all and again I think it's all
gonna depend on how his second movie
does Aquaman 2 is also coming out this
year and I think they've not released a
statement on that for the exact same
reason Jason Momoa has clearly been
working on something with DC that a lot
of people suspect is lobo but it makes
no sense to release news of them being
out before their movies come out anyway
that kind of takes us into the Variety
article which starts off by saying it's
2023 kicks off DC bosses gun and saffron
continue to sift through the rubble and
will soon reveal their three-year
interconnected vision for the Cinematic
Universe which won't include cavill's
Superman or Wonder Woman at all a pretty
big sentence to start with and firstly I
want to go over what this means now good
and saffron have both been going on
about their eight to ten year plan that
all depends on the success of their
Universe in the initial stages they've
actually only signed contract but but
what I think is the next four years and
depending on how well that does they can
keep going or we'll get another reboot
of the reboot yay the second part of
this says that the Slate won't contain
Wonder Woman at all gonna since come out
and debunk this with him saying on
Twitter that it's not true now people at
variety mentioned Cavill but they didn't
mention Godot so whether that means
she's back or not we just don't know
she's one of the only actors from the
original lineup that hasn't released a
statement and we still don't know
whether she's in or whether she's galca
not however gun's statement makes it
seem like she's potentially not out but
who knows we might get that Jennifer
Holland Wonder Woman movie coming up
before we know it and from here it says
but things could have gotten an
alternate Direction behind the scenes a
different group made a play for control
of DC not long after the Warner Brothers
Discovery major closed in April Dwayne
Johnson directly pitched CEO David
zazlab on a multi-layer plan for Black
Adam and a cavalet Superman the two
properties would interweave setting up a
Superman vs Black Adam Showdown sources
say Black Adam producers Haram Garcia
who's Johnson's former brother-in-law
and both Flynn were also part of the
brain trust looking to take DC Down A
New Path other sources confirmed the
meeting but downplayed any discussion of
black Adam's future although the move
took place amid a power vacuum created
as former DC head Walter Hamada and
Warner Brothers film Chief Toby Emerick
prepared to exit it it ruffled feathers
internally sources add Dwayne went
around everyone which didn't sit well
says one now we know that it was the
rock that got the caval Cameo and Hamada
had other plans he wanted Cavill to
cameo in films and then this would
eventually lead to a big return with him
in Justice League 2. the studio were
building towards that but we now know
it's no longer happening because things
have gone in favor of Gunn's new plan
the Bold strategy cotton and whether
this works or not we don't really know
we've already covered The Rock's
statement and though he said there may
be a feature with Black Adam it was very
much a will keep your CV on file and let
you know if any other jobs pop up they
anyway the article then talks about the
caval Cameo even though Toby Emrick was
looking to recast him since 2018. it
then breaks down what could have really
shifted Focus for Warner Brothers with
the performance of Black Adam
potentially being a reason that things
were shut down it says but Black Adam
which bowed October 21st fizzled with a
391 million dollar worldwide Hall
against a 195 budget plus 40 million
dollars in reshoots this scuttled any
plans for more addings with the
lightning bolt-wielding anti-hero an
officially ending the caval Superman era
caval parted ways with his manager
Johnson's ex-wife Danny Garcia this year
but a source says it was unrelated to
the DC drama and she remains a strategic
advisor to the actor meanwhile the
Johnson won his relationship already was
wearing thin after Johnson pushed for
producing credit on the animated film DC
League of Super Pets it's opened in July
but he did little to promote it the
actor also insisted on a tequila bar at
the New York premiere of Black Adam
featuring his Terra Mona Iran despite
the film being PG-13 now that last
sentence killed me a bit anyway which 13
year old wasn't out here drinking
tequila get the audience as drunk as
possible and they might enjoy the movie
I'm just kidding I I thought Black Adam
was fine it was fine it didn't do
anything new but but it was fine now the
article then says his demands increased
and the returns just weren't there no
it's another Insider still box office
analyst Paul durability and says Johnson
found himself in a catch-22 with Black
Adam you can't have a more modest budget
when this level of talent is involved
but it's a commensurate with Talent
involved something with a lower budget
like Shazam is dubbed a hit because hits
are based more on profitability Shazam
and 366 million worldwide in 2019 up a
100 million dollar budget dugara
badanian de garbadeen notes that Black
Adam still managed to crack the box
office top 10 for 2022 so yeah that's
the main point of the article and I
really think the best thing for gonna do
is do a full reset and that will at
least quell some of the fandom that are
going to be mad that their favorites
weren't picked who will become playing
favorites himself if he chooses some
things to keep and not others and it
could end up being an even bigger mess
if some things are wiped and some things
aren't they're doing this because they
see some parts of the dce use a failure
but every project is connected in some
ways for example peacemakers connected
to Suicide Squad and Suicide Squad is
Holly Rick black Captain Boomerang and
Waller who all appeared in the previous
Suicide Squad film I'd add Superman's
death brought up and it also featured
Affleck so it's connected to Batman v
Superman which is connected to Man of
Steel so I just said it is all being
connected even if they wipe stuff it's
gonna make this messy Universe even more
of a mess in my opinion but again we
don't fully know what's happening with
it and those are just the rumors that
are coming out hopefully hopefully the
next video I do will be a big
announcement on the Slate as these
constant drama posts do kind of bug down
the Universe I think and I'd rather be
delivering some good news instead of all
this constant crap anyway that's the end
of the video and obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts we are running a
competition right now giving away Dawn
of the Dead and Black Adam with three
subscribers on the 15th of January and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe the notifications on drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the news repeat the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so that's you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers you want some mails to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our breakdowns linked on screen right
now you can can have a really positive
time you can have a crap on it's
entirely up to you see you over there
and yeah enjoy the rest of your week and
also your weekend you take ASAP peace
thank you